bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir les rapasses du rassemblement
national bonsoir Camille vigogne Le Coat
et merci d'être là les rapasses c'est le
titre de votre enquête choc aux éditions
Les Arènes sur le maire de Fréjus David
rachelin vous révélez l'existence d'un
véritable système Racheline dans le Var
système quasi mafieux où l'argent coule
à Flo vous nous direz pourquoi ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'on est très loin de la
promesse de Marine Le Pen d'une
gouvernance locale exemplaire on en
parle toutes les deux tout à l'heure
dans la deuxème partie notre grand débat
ce soir comment en finir avec l'inceste
dans notre pays la commission
indépendante sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants a
rendu son rapport aujourd'hui 3 ans de
travail 27000 témoignages sans
préconisation et cette parole des
victimes qui se libèent alors est-on
enfin sorti du déni on en parle dans un
instant sur ce plateau avec mes invités
enfin ns affranchis ce soir l'Europe
avec Richard verli le monde d'Isabelle
lasser et puis le mot de la semaine bien
sûr c'est avec Mariette d'grand voilà
pour le menu on y va cam leat ça vous
regarde c'est
[Musique]
maintenant 160000 enf enfants sont
victimes de viol ou d'agression sexuelle
chaque année dont l'écrasante majorité
par un membre de leur famille la stevis
a donc rendu ses conclusions aujourd'hui
elle a travaillé pendant 3 ans recueilli
des dizaines de milliers de témoignages
aux quatre coins de la France et ces
témoignages nous oblige aujourd'hui
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait bonsoir
Édouard Durand bonsoir et merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir vous êtes
magistrat juge pour enfants et
co-président de cette civise vous nous
direz quelles sont les réponses urgentes
à mettre en place parmi la centaine de
vos préconisations bonsoir Arnaud galet
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes membre de la
civise condateur de Moov enfant et vous
venez de publier ce livre j'étais un
enfant chez flamarion c'est votre
témoignage violé à l'âge de 8 ans par
votre grand oncle ainsi qu'à 12 ans par
deux de vos cousins vous êtes
aujourd'hui un activiste ouis l'action
voilà et non plus la victime pour les
Droits de l'Enfant bonsoir Isabelle
Santiago merci d'être avec nous député
socialiste du valdemarne très engagé sur
ce sujet votre proposition de loi sur la
protection des enfants victimes de
violence intrafamiliale on va en parler
elle vient d'être adoptée à l'Assemblée
enfin bonsoir docteur Emmanuel Piette
bienvenue à vous vous vous êtes la
présidente du cfcv le Collectif
féministe contre le viol qui fait un
très gros travail d'écoute des victimes
sur sa plateforme téléphonique on en
parlera également C Camille vigong leat
vous êtes journaliste alors n'hésitez
pas c'est un sujet qui nous concerne
tous à interroger quand vous le
souhaitez nos invités on va commencer
par ce rapport Stéphane lakovski qu'on
accueille tout de suite pour nous en
détailler les principales mesures le
chrono de blackco tout de
suite bonsoir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir toutes et tous alors ce rapport
bah pour commencer je vous propose
d'écouter ce que disait le président
Macron c'était en 2021 au moment où il a
créé cette commission indépendante sur
l'inceste et les violences sexuelles
faites aux enfants
je veux juste vous dire on est là on
vous
écoute on vous
croit et vous ne serez plus jamais seul
on vous croit disait le président bien
justement c'est le titre qui a été donné
au rapport de la commission sur
l'inceste on vous croit vous l'avez dit
myiam 27000 témoignages recueillis avec
des chiffres très choquants que vous
avez déjà cité 160000 enfants sont
victimes d'agression sexu seu ou de viol
chaque année en France et donc ça donne
cette image de toutes les 3 minutes dans
notre pays un enfant est agressé
sexuellement ou violé mais ce qui est
encore plus choquant peut-être c'est
l'identité des agresseurs parce que on
répète souvent aux enfants alors
attention ne parle pas aux inconnus dans
la rue n'accepte pas de bonbon on
imagine toujours que la menace vient de
quelqu'un qu'on ne connaît pas or pas du
tout c'est exactement le contraire ce
que dit la commission c'est que dans 80
% des cas et bien l'agression à lien a
lieu au sein de la famille alors
évidemment lorsqu'un un enfant est
agressé dans sa famille c'est d'autant
plus difficile pour lui d'en parler de
faire entendre sa souffrance et donc le
président en 2021 avait déjà annoncé ça
il disait bah il faudrait que dans la
scolarité de chaque enfant il y ait deux
séances de dépistage une en primaire une
autre au collège pour avoir un adulte de
confiance à qui on aurait pu se se
confier et bien justement c'est la
première recommandation de la
Commission que le président Macron
tienne sa promesse on vous écoute
c'était ce matin sur France Inter
tout le monde dit aujourd'hui personne
ne le conteste dans une classe de 30
élèves il y a trois enfants qui sont
victimes de viol ou d'agression sexuelle
mais
lesquels pour le savoir il faut poser la
question au 30 pour que les trois
enfants victimes puissent se dire ah oui
à mon institutrice à mon professeur je
peux le dire elle va me croire il va me
croire voyez on y revient toujours il
faut croire la parole des enfants
victimes d'agression sexuelle et
pourtant dans le rapport il y a un
chiffre qui prouve que ce n'est
absolument pas le cas je vous laisse le
découvrir vous voyez seulement 3 % des
viols ou des agressions sont punis par
la justice et dans le casre de l'inceste
c'est encore pire seulement 1 % de ces
actes finissent un jour devant le
tribunal alors en même temps si on veut
porter si on veut être que la justice
puisse punir il faut porter plainte et
là on voit aussi que il y a un problème
dans le cas des agressions sexuelles
dans 8 cas sur 10 aucune plainte n'est
déposée dans le cas des incestes car 9
fois sur 10 la justice n'est pas saisie
alors que faire bien la l'autre
proposition les deux que j'avais retenu
en tout cas c'est de la commission c'est
de rendre imprescriptible les crimes et
les violences sexuelles sur les enfants
actuellement les crimes sexuels sont
prescrits au bout de 30 ans mais
regardez parmi les témoins interrogés
dans la commission bien pour les tr/4
d'entre eux le délai était passé donc je
vais vous laisser débattre expliquer les
recommandations de la commission mais
avant je voudrais vous faire entendre la
co-présidente de la commission Nathalie
Mathieu elle a une question à nous poser
à nous tous qu'il faudrait arriver à
comprendre c'est pourquoi on a
peur de faire une accusation à tort et
de détruire une famille par exemple mais
qu'on a pas peur de renvoyer un enfant
se faire violer chez lui tous les soirs
ça ça peut poser question alors c'est
une question j'imagine de à laquelle
vous allez tenter de répondre pendant le
débat mais c'est évidemment une question
qui doit tous nous interpeller
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup merci
Stéphane pour cette présentation
complète Arna galet je voudrais
commencer avec vous si vous le voulez
bien votre témoignage parce que
finalement on retrouve dans votre
témoignage les étapes qu'onure les les
victimes à 8 ans vous êtes violé par
votre grand oncle un prêtre missionnaire
au Gabon vos parents décident qu'il
partagera votre chambre en donnant l'un
des deux lits superposés qu'avez-vous
subi la première chose que j'ai subi
pour moi c'est important j'ai subi déjà
les violences d'un père qui était tout
le monde connaissait sa violence dans le
quartier et dans un milieu plutôt
bourgeois et tout le monde se taisait et
en rigolait donc j'ai été la proie
idéale pour un prêtre pédocriminel je
pense tout simplement parce que ces
violences là éta admise et
inévitablement j'allais pas par j'allais
pas parler de ces viols là à mes parents
ou quoi que ce soit tu Dems que c'était
pas normal et donc pour moi ça c'est le
premier message qu'il existe à mon sens
un vrai continuum de violence au sens
aussi de vulnérabilité au niveau de
l'enfant et je suis vous l'avez dit le
titre de mon livre c'est j'étais un
enfant j'ai m envie de dire j'étais un
enfant parmi 160000 chaque année voilà
donc avec quelque chose qui est très
singulier de triste terrible comme on
dit le courage et cetera qu'on n'arrête
pas de ravacher sans cesse et finalement
d'une banalité absolue quand on regarde
les chiffres et c'est ça moi qui m'anime
grandement aujourd'hui et ce qui est
terrible c'est que je pensais à l'enfant
que j'étais et à tous les enfants et ça
ça me ça me donc vous n'aviez pas
d'adulte de confiance autour de vous ça
c'est important c'était l'omerta
complète parce que vous n avez parlé
pratiquement un peu à votre insu qu'à 19
ans beaucoup plus tard ouais alors après
je dirais quand même que j'ai parlé
d'une certaine manière voyez là où c'est
intéressant c'est que je faisais par
exemple de l'énurésie j'avais pipi au
lit le dire simplement exactement et le
médecin la seule chose qu'il a trouvé de
bon à faire c'était la méthode pipi stop
à l'époque donc pour lui c'était
uniquement mécanique alors que c'était
un signal parmi d'autres de bah de de de
maltraitance et C comme on sait
aujourd'hui et on voit bien que la seule
réponse qui était apportée c'est
celle-là en fait il y av quelque chose
qui était de l'ordre forcément c'était
de ma faute en quelque sorte et donc
acune incapacité d'autant plus pas de
parler quoi d'une certaine manière et
c'est c'est aussi ça le message c'est
que finalement les enfants parlent soit
avec leur mots soit avec leur corps ils
arrivent systématiquement à parler et on
ne les entend pas on veut pas les voir
et c'est ça le message moi qui me semble
important aussi de passer c'est pour ça
je pense que il faut pas qu'on arrive à
à unee certaine manière à à inverser les
choses à dire que ce sont les enfants à
se protéger d'eux-mêmes ou de leur
environnement là où ce sont les adultes
qui doivent les protéger je pense qu'il
y a quelque chose qui est complètement
inversé dans cette histoire en plus de
de secret c'est un peu l'histoire là du
spot he je le dis moi d'emblé au niveau
du spot du gouvernement qui est très
bien bien sûr faut faire le 119 et
cetera mais je suis désolé la petite
fille qu'on voit oui le secret et cetera
bah c'est peut-être aussi parce que soit
on veut pas voir soit on veut pas
l'entendre et c'est ça moi qui m' votre
mère quand elle comprend euh comment
elle réagit dans ma mère ça m'a vraiment
marqué je crois que toute ma vie je je
l'Auris en tête c'estd que moi je je je
dévoile ce qui m'est arrivé devant un
reportage grâce à la télévision grâce au
travail que vous faites voilà c'est
important c'est ça que je suis le
confrère de France 3 c'est ça exactement
sur un documentaire sur la pédophilie
dans l'église et je dis comme beaucoup
de victimes de manière soudaine c'est ce
qui m'est arrivé je me rappellerai toute
ma vie et ma mère ça ve la première
réaction donc je lui explique un peu
puis elle me dit on s'est fait avoir
j'ai pas compris quoi réellement même
encore maintenant enfin bref on a jamais
reparlé d'ailleurs parce que on n pas
une famille on parle beaucoup si je peux
dire les choses comme ça on s'est fait
avoir par le grand oncle par le prêtre
voilà et en fin de compte j'ai compris
après grâce notamment et c'est important
de le dire comme ça grâce à Camille
couchner la famille AG grandandé
c'estàdire toute la dimension finalement
bah ma mère qu'on le voyait non elle
était aussi covictime c'est-à-dire que
c'était son grand onc c'était un prêtre
elle lui donnait le bon Dieu sans
confession je le dis de cette manière-là
et du coup pour elle c'était impossible
improbable alors bien sûr qu'elle a eu
si je dire la négligence je sais même
pas comment on l'appelit de le faire
dormir dans ma chambre alors qu'il y
avait par ailleurs une chambre d'amis et
cetera bref il y avait un truc assez
assez étonnant que j'aurais jamais de
réponse quoi qu'il en soit c'est une
violence aussi sans nom y compris pour
elle quel que soi je DIRIS les
dysfonctionnements que je raconte dans
mon livre également je met aucun doute
au fait que ma mère ait voulu que je
subisse quoi que ce soit mais il y a
quand même cette complexité làble ass
important on Pasir un adulte dans la
chambre d'un enfant autant que si je
comprends bien il y avait d'autres
chambres disponibles mais je renvoie à
votre livre les autres c'est ça qui qui
est un peu sidérant elles étaient pas
rangées allez après 10 ans de suivi
psychologique à 25 ans vous allez vous
souvenir d'un nouveau viol on va pas
forcément rentrer dans les détails
c'était vos cousins mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que vous avez fait une
amnésie traumatique totale j'ai fait une
amnésie traumatique totale de 13 ans
quasiment 13 14 ans et ce que je peux
dire d'emblé et c'est important c'est
que c'est d'une violence sans nom en fin
de compte quand les souvenirs reviennent
moi c'est grâce à un psy que je peux
nommer d'ailleurs parce que je dirais
qu'il m'a sauvé
Jean-Marie for qui qui qui est un
psychiatre qui est assez je pense
reconnu et cetera et qui lui insistait
un peu sur les souvenirs d'enfance moi
j'en avais aucun et cetera et je reviens
au bout d'un moment sur une scène
représentation à théâtrale et cetera
bref les fit me reviennent petit à petit
et lui il pose d'emblé dans son cabinet
je me rappelleris toute ma vie parce que
moi ce qui est important quand même je s
rentrer dans le détail du truc mais moi
je reprends la version de mes agresseurs
qui m'ont toujours présenté ça comme un
jeu qui a été la version d'ailleurs qui
a été accepté par tout le monde et le
psy lui a dit d'embla c'est un viol et
je me rappelle il y a eu un silence
après mais comment ça c'est un viol et
cetera et et effectivement les fitmes
sont revenus et la seule chance que j'ai
et ça c'est important quand même c'est
que mes cousins ont reconnus ils ont
banalisé parce que c'est un jeu
forcément de faire d'imposer une fation
à un autre et cetera c'est tout le monde
sait que c'est un jeu ma famille aussi
pensit que c'est un jeu a priori euh
donc il y a bien cette question de
banalisation et là aussi ça explique
aussi beaucoup de choses par rapport aux
enfants par rapport au témoignages qu'on
peut recevoir justementement sur la
question du soutien social négatif
c'est-à-dire que on vise bien souvent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait la société adopte
ni plus ni moins euh la stratégie de
l'agresseur qui vise sans cesse à
banaliser parce que forcément soit parce
que les filles sont consentantes on le
sait bien parce que la jupe était trop
courte ou quoi que ce soit enfin sens
banaliser ou même le dénis c'est c'est
le mot ouais mais je dirais que le dénis
à la limite ça ça disculpe un peu moi je
pense que de manière très claire on
banalise quoi de manière très claire on
se dit bah non finalement c'est pas si
c'est pas si grave c'est qu'une fation
quoi VO Édouard Duran ce qui est
intéressant c'est que dans tous ces
témoignages il y a des invariant d'abord
la solitude la solitude de de l'enfant
il y a l'amnésie trop traumatique on
voit l'omerta aussi dans la famille il y
a même il y a même la mémoire
traumatique du corps ça c'est c'est vrai
dans votre histoire il y a d'autres
témoignages c'est ça on peut on peut
dresser quelque part une forme de de
d'étape de de voyage en enfer après
après ces faitsl un voyage en enfer oui
absolument je pense qu'il faut voir la
réalité de cette façonlà je pense
d'ailleurs que la docteur Emmanuel Piett
est mieux placé que moi à la fois pour
décrire les invariants dans la stratégie
de l'agresseur et dans les conséquences
sur la santé des victimes dans l'enfance
et toute la
vie tellement
immense que de nombreuses victimes sont
acculées à arrêter la
vie parce que il y a de nombreuses
personnes qui sont venus témoigner à la
civise pour dire moi je voudrais
témoigner aussi pour ma sœur qui s'est
suicidée vous voyez la CIVIS c'est ça
c'est aussi un lieu de mémoire un lieu
de dignité alors expliquez-nous comment
vous avez travaillé 27000 témoignages
30000 témoignages 30000 30000
témoignage et là encore le le cfcv
Emmanuel Piettre et son équipe nous ont
beaucoup aidé puisque c'est le cfcv qui
qui reçoit les témoignages sur la
plateforme téléphonique donc on peut
téléphoner à la ligne violence sexuelle
dans l'enfance on peut renseigner un
questionnaire en ligne on peut écrire
des lettres des mails à la CIVIS et mes
collègues tous les jours sont en en
échange comme ça avec les personnes qui
témoignent et puis on peut venir dans
une audition individuelle pendant une
heure pendant 2h et puis il y a les
réunions publiques et nous sommes allés
partout en
France au début nous savions pas bien ce
que ce serait ces réunions publiques
pourquoi les gens viendraient et puis
nous avons vu dès la première pendant 2h
le micro a circulé de main en main les
personnes
s'applaudissaient et à l'une de ces
réunions publiques il y a une dame qui
qui a attendu la fin de la réunion et
qui a dit je pensais pas prendre la
parole parce que je je je savais pas si
je pourrais et puis j'ai écouté tout le
monde moi je voulais pas parler parce
que quand j'ai été violé j'ai cru que
j'avais perdu toute dignité et en
écoutant les autres j'ai compris que je
n'avais jamais perdu ma dignité et
d'ailleurs Arnaud galet l'écrit aussi
dans son livre rien que pour ça ce
travail est absolument préci besoin
vital de vie ou de mort Emmanuel pied
seulement un enfant sur 10 ne révèle ses
violences au moment des fait pourquoi je
suis pas persuadée de ça parce que je
pense que toujours il le font mais
personne ne les entend c'est toujours ça
exactement vraiment c'est c'est ça qu'on
entend à chaque fois et si on le cherche
on va le trouver vous avez dit à
quelqu'un oui j'ai dit que je voulait
plusetourner chez tonton GG et on l' a
dit quoi il est très gentil tonton GG
mais on n'a pas demandé pourquoi
ou bien je me suis remis à faire pipi au
lit ou bien et ben mes résultats
scolaires ont totalement chuté et
personne ne s'intéresse à savoir
pourquoi cet enfant tout d'un coup va
mal comme ça les enfants victimes ce
sont aussi bien des filles que des
garçons les enfants victimes c'est
plutôt des filles que des garçons mais
reste quand même 20 à 30 % de victimes
qui sont des garçons dans l'enfance et
les agresseurs la grande majorité sont
des hommes la grande majorité sont des
hommes je dirais qu'il y a a beaucoup
coup de femmes agresseuse mais qu'on
n'est pas encore capable complètement de
les en détecter alors on va je fr
circuler la parole voir comment et bien
elle travaille les les écoutantes avant
de parler des pistes de solution je
voudrais que on aille sur le terrain
avec Marion Becker qui s'est rendu au
119 la plateforme de de téléphonie de
l'enfant sans danger vous allez voir
jour et nuit les écoutantes et bien se
relais pour venir en aide aux victimes
reportage d'accord ce sont tes deux
parents qui font
ça d'accord et Ton père il réagit
comment
ça et tu es la seule enfant et celle de
12 ans elle est pas maltraité
elle chaque jour les écoutants du 119
traitent 150 appels ils écoutent les
mères les pères l'entourage et les
enfants eux-mêmes victimes de
violence vous vous êtes un
peu un peu pertur
Pascal vigneron est le directeur du 119
il vient d'être averti d'une situation
d'urgence j'ai eu la voisine la voisine
qui entendu à 5h30 ce matin une enfant
crié arrête de me violer je t'en supplie
arrête arrête j'ai mal arrête et le père
dire ferme ta gueule je ce que je veux
puis il a fermé les fenêtres du logement
donc je je prenis le relais que j'ael le
service de police et j'attends qu'il me
rappelle après intervention pour voir ce
qu'il en estch
immédiate plus de 16000 informations
occupantes sont remonté chaque année au
parquet ou au service de protection à
l'enfance 8 % d'entre elles concernent
des agressions sexuell concernant les
violences sexuelles sur les enfants on
voit effectivement qu'il est en en
évolution hein il est en augmentation
régulièrement ce qui est intéressant
effectivement de la part de de la
commission civise c'est qu'elle met en
exerg effectivement cette cette
problématique pour que il y ait une
mobilisation nationale sur le sujet Léa
reçoit cette fois l'appel d'une mère
inquiète pour son fils elle soupçonne
des agressions sexuelles quand il vous
dit qu'il joue au docteur est-ce qu'il
vous donne des exemples sur ce que ça
veut dire que ça peut être plein de
choses est-ce que ni vous dit pourquoi
il adore comme ça jeou au docteur
pourquoi il y joue tout le temps et
pourquoi il arê d'accord notre travail
premier c'est quand même d'évaluer s'il
y a un danger et de réagir en fonction
et d'orienter dans vers les bons
secteurs après on a vraimentfin on n pas
écoutant pour rien c'est un vrai métier
d'écoute en accord avec la mère Léa va
demander au service de protection de
l'enfance de venir rencontrer la famille
Emmanuel pietre comment elles sont
formées ces ces femmes écoutantes alors
c'est un c'est un mot qui est au féminin
on dit pas les écoutants et les
écoutantes c'est pas les écoutantes de
la permanence violence sexuelle dans
l'enfance qui a repris les appels de la
civise et nous on a plutôt écouté des
adultes qui racontaient ce qui s'était
passé quand ils étaient enfants mais on
a aussi écoutter 5 % de viol qui avait
lieu en ce moment sur des petits enfant
et c'est ça qui moi m'a le plus
impressionné dans cette écoute c'est que
c'était pour une fois il y avait un
parent protecteur une mère en général et
que jamais elles ont on les on les croit
c'estàd elles croit leurs enfants et
l'ensemble du système policier
judiciaire travailleurs sociaux alors on
y vient anille complètement ce qu'elle
dit ça c'est pour l'élu la députée que
vous êtes Isabelle Santiago on comprend
que le soutien il passe pas seulement
que par les proches c'est toute la
société c'est toute l'institution
judiciaire policière la santé
l'éducation vous la trouvez vous les
trouvez à la hauteur ces institutions là
si professionnels sur 10 n'ont pas
protégé les victimes non moi je
considère que en sortant du D sur Cees
sujets là il nous faut et je l'ai dit un
plan global même le texte de loi qui
sera une avancée quand il sera
définitivement adopté alors expliquez-le
nous parce qu'il est important et qui
fait partie des recommandations
d'ailleurs de de la sévice la mesure
phare sur l'orité parentale
évidemment ce que vous venez de dire
c'està-dire de protéger d'abord de
savoir qui on protège donc bien
évidemment nous d'abord protéger
l'enfant et protéger aussi l'enfant avec
son parent protecteur donc du coup
l'éloigner le temps de la procédure du
parent violent du parent agresseur même
s'il n'est pas condamné c'est bien ça
même s'il n'est pas condamné et donc
dans le cadre de la procédure qui elle
peut durer un certain temp par une
suppression une suspension
d'autoritéension voilà une suspension de
l'autorité par parentale etfin de son
exercice de l'autorité parent et en cas
de condamnation le retrait de l'autorité
parentale c'est un texte qui a été
travaillé assez de manière très sérieuse
y compris avec le cabinet du du garde
des saau on a travaillé de manière
transpartisane avec de nombreux
parlementaires parce que sur le plan
légistique il était un petit peu
complexe à faire et il a été largement
adopté à
l'asseméané il il y a le Sénat encore
mais ça devrait ça devrait aller mais
voilà en tout cas ce qui certain c'est
que ce texte de loi serait une avancée à
partir du moment où il va être adopté y
compris je crois que Charlotte cobel
lundi soir quand on l'a discuté à
l'Assemblée nationale annoncé qu'il y
aurait un un décret qui donnerait des
consignes très claires sur ces sujets là
par contre il est clair et je l'ai dit
il est évidemment dans un plan global
libérer la parole d'un enfant il y a
beaucoup de chose il est très très épais
ce rapport 750 pages la prévention le
repérage le traitement judiciaire la
réparation quelles sont le juge durant
quelles sont les mesures à à à prendre
de façon très urgente si vous deviez
nous en donner trois maximum une seule
appliquer les 82 préconisation du
rapport de la civise c'est un ensemble
cohérent vous voyez c'est pas un
ensemble où on pioche bien sûr que ça
prend du temps c'est une politique
publique bien sûr qu'il y a des
préconisations qui relèvent de
changement dans la loi ce que j'appelle
de mes depuis 15 ans une législation
plus impérative il y a des des
préconisations qui relèvent de la
pratique professionnelle la doctrine et
puis il y a des des des préconisations
qui qui impliquent des moyens plus de
moyens parce que le dépistage le
dépistage systématique par un médecin
scolaire ou une infirmière il en faut
des moyens il en manque déjà il faut des
moyens mais le questionnement
systématique c'est d'abord une posture
professionnelle parce que c'est d'abord
une promesse quand on dit qu'il faut
pratiquer le repérage par le
questionnement systématique quand on dit
il faut libérer la parole vous pouvez
vous pouvez révéler les violence que
vous subissez il y a une promesse
implicite si vous dites que vous êtes
victime on va vous
croire le problème est que on dit un
enfant sur 10 on pose la question à 100
enfants avez-vous été victime de
violence 10 enfants vont dire oui et je
vois je fais ce geste mais j'ai reçu il
y a quelques semaines une femme en
elle m'a dit ça comme je enfant ça m'a
bouleversé elle dit un jour à l'école
j'ai failli leer la
main je l'ai pas fait il y a 10 enfants
qui vont révéler des
violences à ne on va dire ce qu'on
t'avait pas expliqué c'est qu'il y a pas
seulement la vérité il y a la vérité
judiciaire h et donc ta
plainte
poubelle dans ces conditions pousser un
enfant à la révélation c'est presque le
mettre en danger c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est un ensemble il y a une
priorité urgence vous pointez quand même
la justice je un ensemble le dénni il
est aussi dans les soins les soins
spécialisés du psychotraumatisme
existent ils ne sont pas dispensés
Camille vigogne vous vouliez réagir oui
non surtout une question pour le pour le
magistrat est-ce que changer la loi
c'est aussi loouable que ça soit c'est
pas mettre une rustine finalement si on
n pas des énormes moyens derrière on
vous entend parler du système scolaire
on a parlé de ENF on connaît tous
l'absence de d'infirmiers d'éducateurs
spécialisés et cetera à quel point c'est
compliqué la crise du système
psychiatrique comment est-ce qu'on peut
est-ce que ça peut avoir un impact de
changer la loi sans mettre énormément de
moyens est-ce que vous êtes confiant
dans le fait d'obtenir ces moyens
demandés très confiant je suis toujours
très confiant quand on travaille avec
des enfants on est en colère mais on est
confiant les enfants sont des des gens
très sérieux deux éléments de réponse le
premier le 12 juin
2023 intentionnel ement nous avons
publié un avis intitulé le coup du
déniis par lequel nous mettons en
évidence que l'impunité des agresseurs
le dénis la passivité ce que le
philosophe Marc RpoN appelle le
consentement meurtrier passif position
confortable du spectateur coûte chaque
année 9,7 milliards d'euros par an
chaque année donc si on se décide à
protéger les enfant on fait une
génération on économise 9 10 milliards
d'euros fois 25 premier élément de
réponse deuxème élément de réponse oui
c'est une question de moyen bien sûr
bien sûr que la protection de l'enfance
bien sûr que la lutte contre l'impunité
des pédocriminels implique des moyens
mais ce n'est pas d'abord une question
de moyens retirer l'autorité parentale à
un père condamné pour viol incestueux ça
coûte 0 centimes et ça protège ça
protège et ça poser la question des
violences à tous les enfants moi j'étais
juge des enfants je posais la question
des violences à tous les enfants poser
la question ou ne pas poser la question
question ça coûte 0 centimes c'est une
question de posture et on entend votre
appel aussi aussi bien mais il faut
soutenir les professionnels la loi mais
à ceux qui nous dirigent aussi parce que
tout n'est pas du du ressort de de la
loi Arna galet qu'est-ce que vous vous
attendez très très précisément au
regarde ce qui est préconisé et surtout
regarde des pouvoirs publics non mais ça
rejoint ce qui été dit là c'estàdire
qu'effectivement faut quelque chose en
fait faut qu'on change de cap en rité
c'est une manière de penser différente
vous savez moi je prends souvent
l'exemple je sais pas c'est le meilleur
peu importe on manque de volonté
politique voyez François Mitterant en
tant que Président il a aboli la peine
de mort plein de gens étaient contre ah
quand même c'est pas possible et cetera
et CEER c'est venu impacter notre
culture par rapport à ça sur le regard
qu'on doit porter aussiamment bah sur
les personnes qu'on commis compris les
pires crimes et cetera parce que c'est
c'est un je pense que c'est la même
chose c'estàdire qu'à un moment donné
quand on voit le dénis aujourd'hui qui
est encore plus important si je dire
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il y a 9
personnes sur 10 qui tournent la tête
d'une certaine manière par rapport aux
enfants tout du moins qu' ne les
protègeent pas
si dans un état de droit c'est pas
l'état qui prend cette décision là d'une
certaine manière de protéger qui la
prend réellement c'est qu'on reste moi
c'est une réforme globale qui
implique les institutions et qui n'est
pas forcément si mais c'est surtout un
principe c'est ça qui est important un
principe de précaution pour les enfants
vous savez on est dans quelques jours on
sera comment dire le le 20 novembre le
20 novembre c'est la journée interale
des droits de l'enfant est-ce que c'est
uniquement une journée où nous adultes
on doit prendre des photos avec des
enfants pour se dire on est content on
aime bien les enfants ou est-ce que
réellement ça veut dire qu'on va
appliquer une bonne fois pour toute la
convention internationale pardon des
droits de l'enfant que la France a
ratifié il y a maintenant plus de 30 ans
vous sortez il se trouve que vous
connaissez bien vous sortez du du bureau
de la ministre en charge de l'enfance
donc Charlotte cobel elle a dit quoi
comment elle a accueilli ce ce rapport
qui veut
répondre des silences qui sont éloqu non
mais moi je ve bien répondre non moi je
pense que ce qu'il faut dire c'est là
que c'est très bien un on est revenu
effectivement sur le fait que on on a il
y avait le discours du président de la
République qui a mis en place la
commission de il y avait les objectifs
et a priori on a coché toutes les cases
donc a priori le travail ben on est ce
que j'ai compris moi vous m'arrêtez
monsieur le juge mais le travail est
plutôt est
plutôt à plutôt été comment dire
valorisé et cetera ça un petit malaise
quand même non non non mais bah
c'estàdire c'est la suite si vous voulez
pourquoi il y a un malaise pour dire les
choses clairement parce que la suite
nous on demande auemment et d'ailleurs
je le mets dans mon livre sans spoiler
mon livre bien entendu la reconduite
misss et d'accompagnement et
d'évaluation parce que une fois qu'on a
dit qu'on partait de loin comme ça
c'est-à-dire que si on dit que ça
disfonctionne c'est pas tout seul que ça
va que ça va changer Emmanuel pi vous
aussi vous attendez la pérénisation
d'une certaine façon de cette commission
et comment mais juste je pensais la
présentation où on disait un enfant
violé toutes les 3 minutes mais non
c'est pas ça parce que c'est des enfants
dans 80 % qui sont violés par quelqu'un
qui connaissent donc ils sont violés
tous les dimanches ou tous les soirs
donc c'est c'est tout le temps donc il
faut pas un enfant toutes les 3 minutes
c'est gantir sa permanence à cette
commission oui bien sû dur également ah
bah évidemment mais l'idée quand même
c'est que on a fait des préconisations
bien maintenant quand on voit la la
résistance la difficulté pour les pour
les gens en général de penser l'horreur
du viol chez les petits enfants parce
que c'est ça la question est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer une grosse verge dans la
petite bouche d'un enfant de 2 ans et
demi non tout le monde a plutôt envie de
voir un bouquet de fleur et du coup
c'est tellement plus agréable de penser
les enfants ça racontent des bobards ou
c'est pas si grave que ça c'est
inimaginable pour les gens qui vont bien
c'est à nous d'ouvrir les yeux et si les
gosses le disent ils ont pas pris un
sexe pour une carotte non c'est un vrai
sexe et ça c'est tellement compliqué à
penser pour les gens qui vont bien qu'
préfèrent penser que les gosses disent
n'importe quoi et nous ce que nous
souhaitons c'est qu'il ait une vraie
principe de précaution que les enfants
soient vra vraiment protégé ils verront
pas leur père si je peux me permettre il
y a quand même je sais pas c'est 80 % de
famille monoparental qui sont des femmes
dont les mecs ne laissent absolument pas
et ça ils vont pas en tô ces mecs là
mais par contre si par hasard une femme
essaie de protéger son enfant alors là
c'est un scandale elle prive l'enfant
bien compris je vrais qu'on termine
quand même par la mesure vous êtes
candidat vous à à votre reconduction
bien sûr bien sûr c'est un
engagement cette continuité je voudrais
qu'on termine par par la question de
l'imprescriptibilité euh rendre
imprescriptible ces crimes contre les
enfants pour quelle raison vous
connaissez vous êtes magistrat vous
connaissez les débats sur la
prescription au bout de 30 ans 40 ans il
n'y a plus de preuve et c'est pour ça ce
que viens dire je voudrais je me permets
ce que vient de dire Emmanuel Piet est
aussi une réponse à la question que vous
posiez c'est la loi qui doit le dire
c'est tellement dur à mentaliser qu'il
faut que la loi le fixe précisément
comme la la proposition de la députée
Isabelle Santiago vous savez dès le 23
janvier 2021 nous savions à la civise
que nous ne pourrions pas esquiver la
question de la prescription ou de
l'imprescriptibilité que nous ne
pourrions pas faire semblant de ne pas
voir que nous devions nous prononcer
alors tout de suite nous avons décidé
qu'il nous faudrait 3 ans humblement
sérieusement après avoir auditionné des
philosophes des pédopsychiatres des
juristes pour nous permettre de nous
prononcer quels sont les fondements de
la
prescription le premier c'est que la
prescription n'est pas un critère de la
gravité qu'une société reconnaît à un
crime le second c'est qu'un des
fondements majeurs de la prescription
c'est la paix
sociale nous parlons en effet de
personnes qui volontairement
consciemment peuvent commettre jusqu'à
1000 viols sur un même enfant peuvent
faire jusqu'à 100 150 enfants victimes50
la paix de qui ensuite un autre
fondement de la prescription c'est la
sanction de la carence du plignant vous
avez parlé d'amnésie traumatique vous
avez parlé d'emprise vous avez parlé
d'un silence qui qui enferme donc pour
vous on peut pas reprocher à la victime
de parler des années après non et
surtout pas pour des raisons de preuve
parce que même quand un enfant porte
plainte quelques jours après les faits
on lui dit il y a pas de preuve alors on
termine avec vous ce débat Isabelle
Santiago parce que c'est à nouveau la
loi qu'il faudrait changer est-ce que
vous y êtes favorable je rappelle que
vous êtes député socialiste dans
l'opposition et que de toute façon il y
a pas de de majorité absolue dans dans
cet hémicycle oui ou non pour
l'imprescriptibilité de ces crimes alors
pour moi c'est très simple c'est oui et
on a déjà essayé sur la dernière
mandature dans le texte que j'avais
porté sur le noncentement et le seuil
d'âge et les question d'inceste en
février 2021 ça avait été déjà discuté
donc il n'y a pas de droit à l'oubli
pour ces crimesl actuellement ça n'a pas
été adopté et il y avait eu une
proposition d'évaluation et une question
aussi sur un amendement qui avait été
avec quelque chose de glissant qui avait
été proposé par le Garde des saau on
verra ce que ça donne encore mais on on
s'arrête cas on est nombreux à le penser
merci beaucoup merci c'était passionnant
de vous écouter merci beaucoup d'être
venu débattre sur LCP arnaau galet
j'étais un enfant c'est à lire aux
éditions flamarion vous restez avec moi
kaville vigong Le Coat dans une dizaine
de minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir Isabelle lasser passe
au crible la critique contre l'Occident
sur un deux poids de mesure dans le
conflit israël-palestinien Richard verli
revient sur Pedro Sanchez le miraculé en
Espagne et puis quel est votre mot de la
semaine Mariette darégrand alors je vais
m'arrêter sur le mot emploi qui fait une
sorte de retour vintage magnifique merci
beaucoup les amis à tout à l'heure mais
d'abord on va partir dans le Var avec
vous Camille vigong Le Coat c'est là que
vous avez enquêté pendant près de 2 ans
à Fréjus précisément la ville conquise
par David rachlim en 2014 les rapaces
aux éditions Les Arènes fitel appui vous
décrivez au fond l'afférisme la
corruption le clienténisme du maire eren
et de son entourage regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier on en parle
toutes les deux juste
après si on vous invite Camille Vigon
lecoat c'est parce que vous avez brisé
l'OM Merta sur l'une des vitrines du
parti de Marine Le Pen la ville de
Fréjus dirigée depuis 2014 par David
Rachlin vice-président du rassemblement
national ave de tempête sur la cité
varoise c'est un système politicofancier
un système quasi mafieux mis en place
par David Rachin où affairisme clanisme
prospère au détriment des citoyens de
vous Camille vigogne lecoat nous
retenons la journaliste grand reporter à
l'OPS après plusieurs années à L'Express
passé par France 5 TF1 et bien sûr par
LCP aujourd'hui vous disséquez
l'exercice du pouvoir du RN 2 années
d'enquête au cœur du système Racheline
vous dites que la corruption et le
clientélisme règne à Fréjus à l'image de
cet entrepreneur local toutpuissant qui
rafle les marchés publics de la ville
vous vous vous êtes plongé dans les
registres de la mairie à la mairie de
Fréjus l'entrepreneur du BTP est comme
chez lui il entre sans rendez-vous dans
le bureau du maire plusieurs fois par
mois sans oublier les déboirs de l'élu
varoi sont train de VI et mesuré au-delà
de ses revenus bijou montre de luxe
l'argent liquide coule à flot l'arbre de
Noël l'appelle certain et vous affirmez
il met souvent le cap sur sainttropé où
il lui arrive de lâcher un SMIC dans une
plage privée car VIP champagne mésimé
espace réservé l'addition se règle
exclusivement liquide des dérives des
dérapages racistes et antisémites aussi
de la part du maire comme de son
entourage jusqu'au salut nazi
personnellement je n'ai jamais entendu
quelqu'un d'aussi antisémite c'est
hallucinant ça confine à la paththologie
témoignage date correspondance contrat
un récit chirurgical sous le feu des
critiques des ténors du rassemblement
national à commencé par la patronne ce
livre est un livre d'une militante
politique bon le titre d'ailleurs le
démontre si la justice considère qu'elle
doit se saisir de ses ragots ou de ses
accusations elle le fera alors Camille
vigogne Le Coat après ce livre explosif
le rassemblement national ne va-t-il pas
finir par lâcher David rachelin c'est
possible ça ce scénario là moi je pense
que l'avenir le dira que si les choses
deviennent trop compliquées pour David
rachl
on il n'est pas assuré d'un soutien sans
faille du Rassemblement National Marine
Le Pen a assuré qu'il avait encore toute
sa confiance jusqu'à preuve du contraire
et tout la il est toujours soutenu par
le clan par Jordan Bardella par Janin
Lacelle bien sûr c'est un des fidèles
des plus fidèles de de Marine Le Pen et
Jordan Bardella Marine Le Pen était
encore au mois de juin sur un voilier
dans le Golf de saint-tropé dans un des
établissement de l'entrepreneur en
question avec David rachelin donc
évidemment il fait toujours partie des
mais en public on observe ces derniers
mois que David Rachin est absent de
toutes les grandes manifestations du
rassemblement national et que Marine Le
Pen ne s'affiche pas en photo avec lui
c'est suffisamment rare et incongru au
regard de ces dernières années pour
imaginer qu'en tout cas il y a une sorte
de prévention des potentielles suites
que pourrait avoir cette affaire
d'autant qu'il y a des éances
électorales importantes qui arrivent
quand il arrive à la tête de la ville en
2014 au terme il faut le rappeler hein
d'une triangulaire fratricide avec deux
candidats de droite s'il y avait pas eu
trois candidats il n'aurait jamais été
élu il promet de la désendetter cette
ville 170 millions de dettes au départ
et Marine Le Pen qui cite régulièrement
en exemple Fréjus pour sa bonne gestion
en réalité c'est c'est tout le contraire
c'est en tout cas sur les deux promesses
de campagne phare de David rachelin le
désentêement de la ville et la fin d'un
système de corruption d'affairisme qui
était à l'œuvre et et ça il faut
vraiment le préciser avant lui déjà dans
le département et dans
l'agglomération bien sûr et le précédent
ma est tombé pour ses raisons et cetera
et et sur ces deux promesses de campagne
on peut dire que David rachelin ne les
tient pas sur l'endettement il a fait
des efforts au début qui ont été salués
notamment dans le premier mandat par la
Cour régionale des comptes mais
uniquement permis par la vente
d'énormément de terrains municipaux ce
qui fait mécaniquement rentrer des des
de l'argent dans dans les caises de la
mairie mais ça a pas suivi sur le le
deuxème mandat tout en continuant à
vendre des terrains il s'est réendetté
réendetté réendetté ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la ville est et dans une
légèrement plus mauvaise situation
financière qu'en 2014 et sur la
dimension affairiste et corruption alors
là il va l'amplifier avec de forts
soupçons de marchés public viciés au
profit du parrain local du BTP il
s'appelle Alexandre barbéot que
Racheline va rencontrer dès le début dès
début 2015 qui est-il précisément
Alexandre Barbot et pourquoi aucun
contrat ne lui échappe dans la région
alors il est surnommé Pacman comme la
petite bête de des jeux vidéos qui
mangent tout par ses concurrents qui ont
très peur de lui ou don Corleon c'est un
homme extrêmement puissant plus puissant
disent absolument tous les acteurs
locaux que les maires de Fréjus sous de
saint-raaphaël c'est l'acteur dominant
dans le BTP est-ce que vous citez un
homme d'affaires installé dans la région
qui vous dit si je parle je prends un
risque pour ma vie bien sûr bien sûr il
y a il y a une vraie omerta on sait tout
le monde sait dans le dans dans dans ce
le sud-est enfin l'est var que comment
Alexandre Barbot tient une partie de sa
puissance de ses liens avec les
politiques et moi ce que j'ai pu
documenter parce que c'est important de
documenter ses faits c'est que il
entretient une relation extrêmement
nourrie avec David Rachin mais mais
comme comme on n voit jamais avec un
entrepreneur c'est-à-dire que plusieurs
fois par mois il y a des déjeunés à son
domicile qui sont organisés il entre on
l'a vu dans le reportage sans frapper à
la mairie David Rachine va sur le bateau
de d'Alexandre barbo il va dans le
l'appartement à Monaco de son ex
beaufère regarder le prix du formul 1 et
tout de suite des enveloppes d'argent
liquide circulent et c'est là que
témoins en plus de toutes sortes de
cadeaux bien sûr des témoins des témoins
m mont raconté avoir observé des
enveloppes en craft chez David Rachin et
certains de ses proches ses enveloppes
en tout cas cet argent liquide qui est
beaucoup dans les poches du maire on le
retrouve dans des achats précis que là
encore j'ai pu retracer alors on va y
venir aux achats mais pour bien
comprendre en gros ces barbéau d'après
tous les témoignages que vous avez pu
recueillir qui donnerait ses enveloppes
en liquide ou ses proches à Racheline en
échange des marchés publics il existe un
fort soupçon de effectivement d'achat ou
en tout cas de de cadeaux visant qui à
expliquer en partie la l'hégémonie de
cet entrepreneur sur les contrats
publics mais aussi en partie sur les
contrats privés parce qu'il faut savoir
que cette entreprise là est présente sur
la plupart des gros contrats privés
pourquoi parce que selon les acteurs du
secteur il ne serait possible d'obtenir
un permis de construire du maire que si
on montre que pour la le raccordement on
passera par l'entrepreneur que pour l'
pour les plan passera par l'architecte
et cetera donc c'est pas seulement
quelque chose qui concerne les marchés
publics euh c'est aussi quelque chose
qui concerne tout le domaine privé c'est
bien de le de le le préciser vous l'avez
dit il flambe Racheline il aime il aime
la fête son surnom c'est c'est la cagole
il adore saint tropé le sujet de Marco
Pomier disait il peut lâcher un SMIC en
un weekend sur une plage tout ça c'est
c'est l'argent de de
Barbro en tout cas c'est de l'argent
liquide la PL c'est pas l'argent de ses
émoluments il gagne environ 8000 € par
mois si on additionne ces différents
salaires publics il sont tous connus
c'est beaucoup c'est un bon salaire mais
ça suffit pas à expliquer ce mode de vie
quelque part si David Rachin était juste
un flambeur ça le regarde c'est sa vie
privée évidemment on a le droit d'aimer
monde de luxe on a le droit d'aimer
faire la fête bon voilà le problème
c'est effectivement la traçabilité de
cet argent d'où vient-il euh moi j'ai
aussi obtenu des enregistrements dans
lequel on entend David Rachin
s'inquiéter on l'entend évoquer l'argent
liquide on l'entend évoquer des
stratagème pour ne pas se faire prendre
en cas de perquisition donc tout ça ce
sont des indices qui jettent un fort
soupçon sur effectivement la source de
ce trin de vie après il m'appartient pas
de qualifier effectivement mais à vous
lire et à lire l'enquête documenter les
différents témoignages que vous
rapportez ça n'est jamais Racheline qui
paye c'est bien pour ça que c'est c'est
pas traçable ce toutes ces dépenses ces
achats se font par un intermédiaire il y
a toujours une forme de prêteon soit
c'est son chauffeur pour la montre à
15000 € soit c'est son ami pour un
bracelet à 6000 h c'est ça la façon de
faire oui la le premier élément matériel
que j'ai réussi à à récolter c'est cette
montre dont on a beaucoup parlé une
montre à 15000 € comment on peut
expliquer aujourd'hui quand on est un
élu de la République qu'on demande à son
chauffeur par ailleurs assistant
parlementaire en partie au au Sénat de
d'aller lui acheter une montre en
liquide au nom du chauffeur et par
ailleurs moi j'interroge David Rachlin
parce qu'on a eu un long entretien dans
son bureau il y a quelques mois et il
niit à quatre ou cinq reprises n'avoir
jamais possédé cette montre et en fait
alors qu'il y a des photos qui t
heureusement quelques quelques mois
avant j'avais demandé un photographe de
de de prendre son poignet en photo et et
j'avais cette mot et et et il ne
changera de version que des mois plus
tard en expliquant avoir reçu un
héritage récupéré de 20 20 ans plus tôt
et d'avoir retrouvé en gros de l'argent
liquide dans son dans le grenier de sa
mère et et ça s mais dans ce cas-là
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir acheté lui enfin
il y a des choses qui sont absolument
incompréhensibles et et qui jettent
effectivement un fort soupçon sur
l'origine de cet argent cette manière de
faire on voit le signal aux employés
municipaux que que tout est permis d'une
certaine manière vous aussi que dans
l'attribution des logements sociaux on
réserve les meilleurs aux Français et
les plus endommagés voire vétustes au
bououle comme les appellent l'adjointte
au logement oui ce qu'on ce que j'ai pu
documenter c'est un une atmosphère où
les propos racistes n'était étit au
minimum non sanctionnés voire parfois
encouragés sous couvert d'humour dans le
cadre des logements sociaux c'est une
sorte de préférence nationale qui dirait
pas son nom on note aussi que la jointe
au logement à réservver un très beau
logement pour sa propre fille à loger
également des militants du rassemblement
national qui arrivit parfois d'autres
régions très lointaines tout ça ça
raconte en fait un système où de
l'association sportive à la police
municipale en passant par les logements
comme le maire prend beaucoup de
largesse avec ce qu'il peut faire ou ce
qu'il est censé faire on s'autorise des
choses similaires dans les services
municipaux c'est le ruissellement mais
façon euh façon tout est permis h il ne
dit rien non plus quand son ancien
directeur général des services Philippe
lotio qui est député ici à l'Assemblée
national va faire un un faux certificat
vaccinal pour le covid il y a énormément
de scèes j'ose dire des des anecdote
est-ce que vous avez subi des des
pressions Camille Vigon le CAT est-ce
que vous avez même été intimidé au cours
de cette enquête j'ai je n'ai pas je
n'ai pas eu de raison de de craindre de
façon lourde en revanche que j'ai pu
observer c'est un une mise à l'abri
totale du parti en l'occurrence même ici
à l'Assemblée nationale le secrétaire
général du groupe qui a intimé l'ordre
aux 88 députés du rassemblement national
de ne plus me parler sous prétexte que
j'étais une militante pour la première
fois de ma vie les députés m'ont donné
rendez-vous loin de l'Assemblée à dans
d'autres arrondissements pour ne pas
être vu c'était euh c'est mais il me
parle encore heureus heureusement
toujours on a toujours des menace de
déposer vous l'avez reçu je n'ai
toujours pas reçu de plainte il a
beaucoup communiqué sur ce dépôt pour
l'instant ni moi ni l'éditeur n'avons
reçu quoi que ce soit et si ce livre
débouché sur une enquête judiciaire avec
des perquisitions sur la base de ce que
des éléments que que vous avancez est-ce
que ce
serait forme de de bonne chose verons
nous le verrons le le temps judiciaire
est un temps plus long que le temps
journalistique euh moi en l'occurrence
j'ai consacré ces derniers mois à
documenter des faits euh à faire mon
travail de journaliste et je laisse
évidemment la justice faire Leen merci
beaucoup Camille vigong Le Coat les
rapass enquête sur la mafia varoise de
Marine Le Pen c'esté à lire aux éditions
Les Arènes on termine si vous le voulez
bien avec nos affranchis place à leur
parti prix tout de
suite bienvenue les affranchis alors on
change un tout petit peu les visages du
vendredi mais on est ravi Isabelle
lasser du Figaro pour les pages Diplo
Richard Verly du quotidien Suisse B
bonsoir On va commencer avec vous
Mariette Mariette d'égrand vous avez
choisi le mot emploi cette semaine
pourquoi j'étais un peu surprise de le
voir revenir surtout dans des
expressions comme plein emploi ou emploi
en tension parce que moi j'en étais
resté Miriam on fait que Paul emploi
allait laisser la place à France travail
alors ce changement finalement ça pas
l'air d'être fait en tout cas c'est
peutêtre en cour voilà mais on a plutôt
l'impression que le mot emploi reprend
du poil de la bête alors pour moi ça
fait un peu penser quand même au trente
glorieuse au moment où justement la
question de l'emploi n'était pas encore
complètement impactée par les crises qui
ont donné lieu au chômage de masse donc
c'est un retour un peu vintage et je
pense qu'il s'explique par le
dictionnaire ce retour parce que le mot
est très ancien c'est un mot tout à fait
intéressant un mot du du dire du
Moyen-Âge d'ancien français et qui vient
de plier l'action de plier l'employé de
maison du 19e se plier le linge hein
toujours et puis bien bien sûr il y a
d'autres matières que l'on peut plier le
bois l'acier toutes sortes de matières
et du coup ployer et employer est devenu
bah un terme générique et alors est-ce
que c'est ce vieux sens qui nous rit
l'expression emploi en tension dont on
parle notamment dans dans les métiers
comme la restauration le BTP la
menuiderie en ce moment alors d'une
certaine façon oui parce que souvent ce
sont des métiers anciens pour lesquels
les techniques n'ont pas été transmises
hein par exemple la
menuiserie carleur des métiers comme ça
et M même pharmacien j'aiété assez
étonné d' un métier en tension
aujourd'hui bon qui n'ont pas vraiment
été on sait qu'on a un problème en
France avec la transmission du technique
mais il y a une autre raison alors là
qui tient à la valeur du mot plutôt au
18e siècle au moment où le théâtre est
très florissant et vous savez quand on
parlait d'emploi de jeunes ingénu ou
d'emploi de jeunes premiers à ce
moment-là on était pour toute sa vie
finalement assigné à un rôle classique
et ça je trouve que c'est tout à fait
intéressant par rapport à la question
politique parce que c'est comme si nos
politiques restaient peut fixé sur cette
vision de l'emploi hein une personne a
une employabilité une employabilité pour
toute la vie or ce que montrent les gens
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils font
extrêmement vari leur travail je vais
prendre deux exemples dans ce qu'on
appelle les sociologues du travail
appelleent vous savez les travailleur
slashheur par exemple un jeune plombier
le jour qui peut la nuit être un
chanteur rappeur et puis le weekend
Bours côteur par exemple ou une jeune
aide soignante qui peut aussi être une
influenceuse beauté et puis une Rev
vendeuse de produits seconde main c'est
ça qui se passe dans la société
c'est-à-dire les gens font varier la
manière dont ils travaillent alors ça
m'amène à pour finir à poser cette
question disons au corps politique en
général pas simplement à notre ministre
du travail et du
plan l'emploi mais est-ce que la
question n'est pas aujourd'hui de avoir
une vision moins homogène de
l'employabilité d'une personne hein
parce que si on on est comme ça bah on
dit il a pas la formation et cetera mais
si on voit comment les gens font varier
ce terme à ce moment-là on voit que ça
ouvre aussi des perspectives je pense
beaucoup plus intéressantes mais là et
c'est une question un petit peu dure
pour les politiques c'est je me demande
ce qui manque si ceux qui manque
d'employabilité bah ce n'est pas leur
propre logiciel pour regarder tout ça
changer bien compris bien reçu merci
beaucoup Mariette l'itinéraire d'un mot
qui fait l'actu et chaque vendredi avec
plaisir comme toujours avec vous le
monde d'Isabelle Lasserre bonsoir
Isabelle vous nous emmenez sur une
accusation qu'on entend qui est très
répété ces derniers jours ces dernières
semaines elle vient des pays du Sud le
fameux Sud global qui voit un deux poids
de mesures contre l'Occident notamment
dans le conflit entre Israël et le Hamas
oui miram alors c'était déjà le cas
depuis le début de la guerre russe
contre l'Ukraine mais là depuis que le
conflit entre Israël et le Hamas a
repris les invective fuse contre
l'Occident le sud global reproche une
soi-disant hypocrisie il reproche aux
États-Unis et à l'Europe d'avoir de
pratiquer le deux poids de mesure dans
toutes les crises internationales alors
les reproches c'est vous aidez l'Ukraine
et pas les Palestiniens vous avez
abandonné la cause palestinienne vous
vous occupez que des victimes juives et
pas des victimes palestiniennes alors ça
elles sont elles sont vraies ou elles
sont fausses ces accusations alors
certaines sont vraies il est vrai que
l'Occident a eu des indignation
sélective il a utilisé la force contre
certains dictateurs on se souvient de
sadamus de kadfi de Milosevic mais il
s'est accommodé de certains autres ça a
été notamment le cas en Afrique mais
beaucoup sont fausses sur le dossier
palestinien notamment il a certes été
mis entre parenthèses ces dernières
années mais avant ça qui s'est occupé
d'essayer de trouver une solution
politique en permanence en permanence
les États-Unis qui déverse des milliards
d'euros pour les Palestiniens l'E c'est
l'Europe alors
euh les pays en fait tous les les
personne n'a rien fait pour les
Palestiniens les pays arabes ont mis le
dossier complètement entre parenthèses
je ferai une exception pour le Qatar qui
il est vrai euh payent les salaires des
fonctionnaires Palestiniens alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle révèle cette mulation
par que ces pays où étaient-il quand la
Russie envahissait l'Ukraine il nétaiit
pas du côté des victimes ils étaient
plutôt du côté russe est-ce qu'on les a
entendu quand le Yémen était bombardé et
était victime de crise humanitaire
est-ce qu'on les a entendu pendant les
les exactions des roinga en Birmanie non
pas du tout alors qu'est-ce que vous
pensez-vous sur le fond de ces
accusations qu'est-ce qu'elle révèle al
cette accélération en fait de la de la
contestation contre les démocraties
occidentales révèlent en fait une
véritable rupture politique les pays du
Sud global qui sont emmenés aujourd'hui
par la Chine et par la Russie surtout
depuis la la guerre l'invasion russe de
la de l'Ukraine ont pour objectif de
changer l'ordre international de 1945
celui qui a été dominé par les
États-Unis la plupart d'entre eux ne
sont pas du tout tout attaché à la
démocratie ils veulent vraiment changer
complètement les règles du jeu et
reprendre le pouvoir les accusations en
fait qu'il proffèrent contre les pays
occidentaux régulièrement n'ont pas de
rapport avec les faits ils sont liés à
l'idéologie depuis la guerre d'Ukraine
aujourd'hui tout le monde trouve une
bonne excuse pour détester les
occidentaux le problème c'est que ce
combat qui dépasse largement en fait le
conflit entre Israël et le Hamas donc
entre les Juifs et les Palestiniens
commence à prendre une une couleur de
choc
civilisationnel merci beaucoup pour ce
parti prix Richard verli vous vouleez
revenir sur la réélection de de Pedro
Sanchez le miraculé en Espagne qui prend
des risques he parce que il s'allie avec
les indépendantistes qui n'étaiit pas
forcément ses principaux amis au départ
oui alors il y a deux manières de lire
l'investiture qu' a finalement obtenu
jeudi Pedro Sanchez par 179 députés
espagnols sur 370 qui va lui permettre
de continuer à gouverner le pays a
priori pendant 5 ans la première c'est
une lecture politicienne et tactique on
l'a pas mal vu voilà donc un premier
ministre de 51 ans qui prouve sa
dextérité et qui confirme son statut de
dirigeant insubmersible le Parti
socialiste de Sanchez rappelons-le était
arrivé derrière les conservateurs aux
élections européenne de juillet 2023 il
a renouvelé son alliance avec soumar le
parti de la gauche radicale et il a
scellé un accord avec les
indépendantistes catalan sur une loi
d'amnistie ça lui a permis de trouver
cette courte majorité a priori sol ce
qui après tout est le propre des régimes
parlementaires où tout dépend de la
coalition que vous parvenez à former
alors la seconde lecture elle est
européenne en sauvant son poste Pedro
Sanchez maintient au pouvoir la gauche
dans un pays crucial de l'Union
européenne mais il le fait en acceptant
un accord avec les indépendantistes dont
le projet est de démanteler l'État
espagnol ce qui permet aux critiques de
s'engouffrer en parlant de trahison
nationale et si c'était vrai et si
c'était les indépendantistes finalement
Catalans les les vainqueurs de cette
élection et bien écoutez moi je ne le
pense pas je pense qu'il s'agit d'une
critique assez infondée bien sûr la loi
d'amnistie que les indépendantistes
catalons obtenu va redonner de l'oxygène
et va permettre notamment le retour en
Espagne de leur leader Carlos pichdemon
qui est exilé en Belgique et après
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire il fallait
les boycotter il fallait maintenir un
certain nombre de personnes en prison
maintenir P dememon en exil il fallait
partir du principe que la seule réponse
à la revendication d'indépendance doit
être la force la réalité qu'à travers
cette alliance Pedro Sanchez mise sur
les institutions de son pays il paraît
aussi il parie aussi sur la fatigue
indépendantiste y compris en Catalogne
en clair ce premier ministre doué
charismatique il a poussé les bons pions
on peut juger son calcul risqué mais ne
pas écouter les électeurs
proindépendantistes aurait peut-être été
une trahison démocratique merci beaucoup
Richard en tous les cas c'est l'un des
derniers dirigeants d'un grand pays
d'Europe de gauche vous vous qui
connaissez bien les les populismes de
droite s ils vont tout rafler vous
pensez aux prochaines élections
européennes c'est c'est en en France ils
ont des sondages qui sont extrêmement
favorables mais c'est vrai qu'en Espagne
on a été surpris par le le score
finalement moins élevé que ce qu'on
attendait de de box notamment donc
écoutez on va on va je vais pas me
risquer à faire des pronostics
électoraux mais on verra dans quelques
semaines merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS
Camille vigong lecoat Mariette d'égrand
Isabelle lasser Richard verli merci les
aanchis et à très vite c'est le weekend
profitez bien merci aussi à toutes les
équipes d'lcp derrière la caméra qui ont
R du possible cette émission à la
semaine
[Musique]
prochaine